[Music]
after a month of just working with my
dancers I looked at them and I said whoa
they look like a real company and then I
also said Wow Cambodia's first gay dance
company just formed in my living room
[Music]
my name is Bronson Alcott
my classical dancer and choreographer
[Music]
my classical dance is an art form that's
more than a thousand years old art form
has animus hindu-buddhist roots and it's
uh all at once a form of entertainment
form of worship and also a form of
educating the people in 1970s in
Cambodia the Khmer Rouge took over the
country and they were a group of radical
communists who wanted to eliminate all
forms of elite culture because of this
Kamiya classical dancers were targeted a
third of the entire population died and
in that number were 90% of kamae dance
artists so it was a real tragic loss
because Kamiya classical dance is not
passed on in a book
[Music]
the act of reviving this artform of
preserving this artform is really much
so a protest against a legacy of
violence and it's really much so a
gesture of resilience of beauty a
resilience of the human spirit
[Music]
I was born and raised in Long Beach
California which is home to the largest
my diaspora outside of Southeast Asia I
realized that if I wanted to make the
biggest impact on the artform I had to
do it from Cambodia so in 2015
I started Bramson alguna Arase which is
Cambodia's first gay dance company we
have two primary missions one is to
preserve the art form but also creating
new work that reflect our experiences as
LGBTQ people in Cambodia I felt like I
really opened up a door for many young
men who have always loved classical
dance but never had access to proper
training these young men all of a sudden
had someone that they can seek that
knowledge from my friends are often
surprised when I say this but in certain
ways I feel that Cambodia is much more
tolerant and open it comes to LGBTQ
issues than other places there have been
some people maybe they don't like gay
people or LGBTQ people but when they see
the rigor of the dancing the rigor of
the costumes when they see the artistic
quality they realize that it's coming
from a place of real love and real
respect and real devotion and they also
see a sense of hope for the future
[Music]
I hope that in the future we take care
of this art form as beautifully as we
can both traditionally but then we also
use this art form to just create things
that would make our ancestors say wow I
never would have imagined that
[Music]